i don't think there's anything there
again you know to to what peter said how
do you know if we don't know what's on
the table we'll see
what's on the table you'll let me finish
my answer illusions okay
you want to come to the conclusion that
they're exonerated without knowing
what's going on
can i state my case big mouth shut up
okay so yeah i don't think there's
anything there again i don't think
there's anything there i don't think
there's anything there because you don't
a credential crew with patriot stuff on
not like anybody would be watching them
peter king just didn't know what to do
it was like that's awesome
that is awesome well done in the back by
the way um i won that argument thank you
no you didn't no you didn't shut up yeah
airing of grievances
uh go ahead all right well yeah you know
i'm i'm sick of talking about this but i
don't have many grievances right and
this is i wanted to talk about maybe
about people always way to sell it way
to sell well i'm selling that we've hit
a few other grievances already in the
show that i had written down i didn't
know we were going to talk about phillip
rivers and yannick and gawkway to start
the seven o'clock hour that was going to
be one of my grievances is him yelling
at him for no reason after a guy helped
him out okay you know the patriots chris
chris that the radio audience hasn't
heard about that
i'm going to go there
me play football me play quarterback me
just throw to open receiver what coach
says okay i'm going to go sometimes i'm
going to go there okay can i do that i
am i have a problem with what phillip
rivers did the other day throws a throws
a screen pass you know one yard behind
the line of scrimmage the guy runs from
her 90. all right yannick and goku hits
him picks him up like very respectful
manner showing good sportsmanship and
then phillip rivers goes down field
and
finds him where he's about 10 yards in
front of him and starts yelling in his
ear 90 yard touchdown like taunting him
without trying to make it it's like a
passive aggressive taunt all right and i
have issues with that right because
first of all it's wrong i do think the
referee should have thrown an
unsportsmanlike conduct thing there if
it was the other way around and the
defense had done that to the offensive
player i think that there would have
been a penalty on the defensive player
but the quarterback you know i don't
know they get away with that kind of
crap so to me i like phillip rivers and
his trash talking a lot i do i think
that went overboard into bad
sportsmanship and just a low blow and
kind of kicking a guy when he's down
after he just respectfully showed great
sportsmanship and picked you up off the
turf
i agree with you and look
it's it's hard for me to reconcile well
it's not that hard i think it was
incredibly entertaining yeah i got a
kick out of it right but i think philip
rivers was in the wrong right it was
funny it was funny to see him do what he
did but he shouldn't have done it yeah
yeah that that that's how i feel too
like yeah it was okay i i watched the
clip a few times too but i also came
around who came away going like man that
was
just like a jerk move by phillip rivers
and and i'm all for talking crap i
really am to me that just crossed the
line a little bit
all right here's mine yeah and we see
this every time the nfl is getting ready
to have one of its quarterly meetings
and they have their quarterly meetings
in texas today
the nfl will leak something to its
in-house media operation some
significant fact about an agenda item or
something league related and the leak
yesterday to nfl network was that in the
off season the nfl will conduct a
comprehensive top-down review
of everything about officiating right
including whether or not any changes
need to be made to who is responsible
for conducting replay review
in isolation i think that's fine
i don't think it's fine
that it was leaked now what does it do
now
to make anything better for anyone is
anyone going to say well i'll continue
to watch these games that are marred by
bad officiating because i know a
top-down review of officiating is coming
after this season ends and meanwhile
you've put more pressure on everyone
there's already ungodly pressure on al
river on the senior vp of officiating
and now you got more pressure on him
because he's officiating or replay
reviewing or doing whatever it is that
he does for his job
from now until the end of the season
it's not fair to put that pressure on
him right it's not fair to put that
pressure on everyone beneath him and
that could end up actually making things
worse chris uh agreed i think that was
the point you hit like the nail on the
head there i mean the fact that they
brought it up now
going into the most crucial time of the
year
to say hey all you guys who have been
under a microscope we're going to
increase it a little bit more and you
know we're going to tell everybody is
basically what they said is we're not so
sure our refs have done a very good job
this year we're going to review all of
them and maybe fire some of them as we
get down to the last three games of the
regular season into the playoff stretch
i'm with you it's just not a good look
for the nfl it compromises the officials
it makes al riveron look like he's he's
he's been wrong a lot this year uh as
far as calls and things like that so
there's so many issues right now
on that side of football and it's
problematic it bothers me i'm old school
i just want to see football and players
play and do that and this has dominated
our 100th season
way too much and it's annoying
and it encourages more complaints
because anytime there's a bad call or
something that we think may be a bad
call you're gonna be able to say well
now we know why they're gonna do a
top-down comprehensive review of
officiating right after the season ends
yeah it just it it benefits no one and
uh it potentially makes things worse
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports